[Music]
why do humans drink so much milk and
given that all mammals lactate why do we
favor certain types of milk over others
milk is the first thing we drink and
thanks to developments in the production
and variety of dairy products it can
take on countless forms for our dietary
and sensory well-being milks primary
function is as a complete source of
nutrition for newborns in fact since it
has all of the vital nutrients for
development and growth proteins
carbohydrates fats vitamins and minerals
and water milk is the only thing a baby
even needs to ingest for the first 6
months of life the unique makeup of milk
can vary depending on factors like
species diet and location reindeer of
the Arctic Circle for example make
energy dense milk that's about 20% fat
roughly 5 times more than human or cow's
milk to help their young survive the
harsh freeze and climate so how is milk
made in the uniquely mammalian process
of lactation a special class of milk
secreting cells known as mamuh sites
line up in a single layer around
pear-shaped alveoli those cells absorb
all of the building blocks of milk then
synthesize tiny droplets of fat on
structures called smooth endoplasmic
reticula the droplets combine with each
other and other molecules and are then
expelled and stored in spaces between
cells mammary glands eventually secrete
the milk through the breasts utters or
in the rare case of the platypus through
ducts in the abdomen although this
process is typically reserved for
females in some species like Dayak fruit
bats goats and even cats males can also
lactate milk drinkers worldwide consume
dairy from buffalo goats sheeps camels
yaks horses and cows almost all of these
species are ruminants a type of mammal
with four chambered stomachs that yield
large quantities of milk of these cows
were the most easily domesticated and
a milk that is both easily separated
into cream and liquid and has a similar
fat content to human milk in their
natural environment mammals secrete milk
on call for immediate consumption by
their young but with the demands of
thirsty consumers the dairy industry has
enlisted methods to step up production
enhance shelf life and provide a variety
of milk products in the dairy
centrifugal machines spin milk at high
speeds
forcing less dense fats to separate from
the liquid and float up after being
skimmed off this fat known as butter fat
can be used in dairy products like
butter cream and cheese or it can be
later added back to the liquid in
varying proportions to yield different
fat content milks full fat milk
sometimes referred to as whole milk has
3.25 percent butterfat added compared to
1 to 2% for low and reduced fat milk and
less than half a percent for skim milk
to stop re separation of the fat from
the water or creaming the mixture
undergoes the high-energy pressurized
process of homogeneous Asian before milk
hits the shelves it's also typically
heat treated to reduce its level of
microbes a government-sanctioned process
that raw milk enthusiasts argue may
reduce milks nutritional worth milk
spoilage is started by microbes which
consume and break down the nutrients in
milk that process causes butterfat to
clump together leading to a visually
unpleasant product and the byproducts of
the microbes consumption are compounds
that taste and smell nasty but there's a
bigger problem raw milk can carry
microbes that are the sources of deadly
diseases so in order to kill as many of
those microbes as possible and keep milk
fresh longer we use a technique called
pasteurization one version of this
process involves exposing milk to about
30 seconds of high heat another version
called ultra high temperature processing
or ultra pasteurization blasts the milk
with considerably higher temperatures
over just a few seconds
UHT milk boasts a much longer shelf life
up to 12 months unrefrigerated compared
to pasteurized milks two weeks in the
fridge that's because the higher
temperatures of UHT processing
inactivate far more microbes yet the
higher processing temperatures may
adversely affect the nutritional and
sensory properties of the milk
ultimately that choice lies in the
consumers taste and need for convenience
fortunately there are many choices
available in an industry that produces
in excess of 840 million tons of
products each year
[Music]